a tri-service guard of honor
makes its way into position
on the east side of parliament square
the royal navy army and royal air force
with colours draped and accompanied by
the band of hm royal marines with drums
draped and muffled
moving into position
they will be there to welcome the coffin
and the gun carriage
as it heads towards westminster hall
and like the lying in state
departing wellington barracks
members of the public are being urged
now to move towards hyde park
all ceremonial viewing areas are now
full
there are screens for people to watch at
hyde park corner was the operation
name for
the death of king george vi and it was a
cold february was it not when his body
was brought back by train
from sandringham also died on holiday
and the shock then
dying at the age of 56 we feel shocked
at the queen dying at 96.
i think it was james pope hennessy who
wrote about a sort of national obsession
people wore dark armbands
the frontage of shops was blacked out
people were genuinely astonished and of
course it was was unexpected although
he'd been a very sick man a lot of that
had been hidden from public view he'd
but a few days earlier waved off at the
edinburgh as they were known then philip
and elizabeth to go on this
extraordinary commonwealth tour and then
the the young now queen of course
returning to britain uh and people sort
of projected onto her their ideas of
this vulnerable queen you know the sort
of tremorous queen but in fact
a lot of the observers at the time her
private secretary and people working
with her said that very quickly she
assumed the mantle of state and from the
word go there was a quiet
self-possession that struck them all
even churchill who when he was greeted
with the news of the death of the late
king he said bad news it's the worst he
said of course they had developed a keen
bond meeting weekly throughout the
second world war and when he was
consoled well you've got a wonderful new
queen he said she is but a child but
very quickly he was enamored and very
very struck by her self-assurance i
think he referred to it as her
reflectiveness and her authority in but
an infant using churchill's slightly
retro phrasing of the time
hm royal marine band is also preparing
to move off
the stage is now set at buckingham
palace
the lifeguards on the north side the
blues and royals on the south side and
in front of the center arch the first
battalion cold stream guards
stood waiting
for members of the public
themselves waiting
often for hours to watch this
they have their own memories of the
queen a sparkling smile
let's listen
uh
[Applause]
good afternoon from bucknell palace
it is two o'clock the queen will leave
for the final time shortly
at 2 22 her majesty's coffin will be
taken on a gun carriage to westminster
hall where she will lie in state until
her funeral on monday
the king will be accompanied by his
siblings and his sons as he walks behind
his mother's coffin
westminster hall will then be open to
the public
from 5 p.m
with a queue already building the public
warned they may have to wait more than
24 hours to fall past the queen as she
lies in state
until the morning of her funeral
on monday
tessa dunlop royal historian is here
with me
rhiannon mills our royal correspondent
too
and there is so much preparation we are
on that goes into this
over the years and this week
by dawn and it overnight
to make this
the best it can be as we see the minute
guns preparing
to be fired
the queen had so much love and respect
for her armed forces as
commander-in-chief
but also as a veteran herself having
served in the auxiliary territorial
service during the second world war
as a military wife and
as a military mother
she had this deep heartfelt appreciation
and always cared so much
about the personnel
and about their families
and of course those
very unique british military ceremonies
always accompanied those huge milestone
moments
that she marked throughout what was an
extraordinary 70-year reign
it was only three months ago that we saw
that final troop in the color for queen
elizabeth ii to mark her official
birthday a moment that was accompanied
by
this wonderful celebratory music um an
extraordinary sight of british military
pageantry today there will largely be
silence
as we see what is being described as a
relatively small personal procession
ahead of the full ceremony of the state
funeral on monday we'll hear that
and people if they're just turning on
now tuning in they'll notice the
predominant military theme very fitting
really when you bear in mind the queen
was the last living head of state to
serve in world war ii
hmm
the final few minutes for the royal
family to say privately goodbye to their
mother
king charles leading his siblings
will walk behind the gun carriage on its
way
to westminster hall
oh
[Music]
the tri-service guard of honor makes its
way to the east side of parliament
square in preparation
for the royal party to arrive
led by the band of the royal marines
[Music]
as the band and the honor guard
move off there is a sense of calm at
buckingham palace
as they await her majesty's coffin
alastair bruce
minute guns will be fired from hyde park
there is a sense of drama about this
afternoon
second preparation and
at very little notice
but according to a plan well made
the armed forces are about to
convey the late queen to her final
public duty
of lying in state
for the people to come and pay their
respects
[Music]
marching down bird cage walk where the
stuart kings from whom the late queen
descended
used to
have their aviaries
on the way towards parliament
square
parliament square itself was the island
of thorns
where literally there was an island on
which
king edward the
confessor in the early 11th century
built himself a palace
and founded an abbey to saint peter
which
was known as the minister
in the west the minster in the west and
became westminster
and it is there that later on
the queen's funeral will take place on
monday next week meanwhile waiting
in the park
the king's troop royal horse artillery
are ready to fire the minute guns which
will
punctuate
the progress of the procession from
buckingham palace
down the mile across
horse guards
under the arch which is the ceremonial
exit from the royal palaces
and on to whitehall
finally into
parliament street parliament square
and into the palace of westminster
this is all about delivering the queen
for the public
and many have come to watch
as the lake queen passes by on the mull
but not far away huge numbers are
gathering in order
to file past the lake queen in
westminster hall
the doors will be opened at around five
o'clock
and they will remain open 24 hours a day
while the vigil is kept over the lake
queen by
soldiers from the household division
and by the various royal bodyguards
of england
and scotland
and standing outside the gates which
lead to clarence house
where the king and queen consort are
still living and also lancaster house
members of the
royal household there
for young children who probably don't
know quite what this is all about
history
is reflected in what they see and for
those who worked
in the royal household the loss
of the late queen very deeply felt by so
many in fact this morning
many came to buckian palace and had the
chance to
pay their respects
in the bow room
just looking out towards the gardens
of the palace
the ceremony is very simple
the gun carriage which went into the
palace some time before
we'll wait until the coffin is brought
from buckingham palace and placed upon
it
and then the king's troop royal horse
artillery is exactly 22 minutes past two
will start their procession
to westminster hall
along the way
salutes will be given
to elizabeth ii
by soldiers sailors
and men and women
and royal marines
but this is for the public
and it is
their chance to
take time
to say thank you to the queen coming
down
third birdcage walk
the band of his majesty's royal marines
[Music]
leading the senior service the royal
navy
the queen's father
her husband
and two of her sons served in the royal
navy
an island race that
respects the importance of its navy to
protect the shores
of the kingdom
followed by
the grenadier guards
it was 1942 that princess elizabeth was
asked by her father king george vi
when times were pretty hard in the
second world war
for her to become the colonel of the
grandeur guards
she's held a very close relationship
with them right the way through
to the end of her reign and we will see
the grenadiers play a very
treasured role
as their responsibility their
queen's company
is to guard
the queen's coffin
and the royal air force
as a young woman
princess elizabeth and her sister
princess margaret rose like so many
others
of her generation looked into the
skies above
london and watched the dogfights take
place between
the spitfire
and the messerschmitt from the luftwaffe
of nazi germany
and
so she knew the importance of it
horse guards arch which looks out
towards
the war memorial the guards memorial at
the far end
people have been gathering here for some
time a huge sense of anticipation
and wherever you are watching this you
will come with your own thoughts
about a queen whose
image has been a constant
on the stamps
on the coins
on the bank notes
on television
at major national events
but this god's memorial is still
pockmarked with the impact of munitions
that were dropped during the blitz
and winston churchill
the queen's first prime minister
gave instruction that it should be left
entirely unrepaired
um
so many memories here represented
as the band of her majesty's royal
marines collingwood
under their principal director of music
the tongue
coming into
parliament square
the muffled drums
a reflection of the period of mourning
for the late queen
each of the drums which normally show
the symbols of the royal marines
and all the bravery that they've shown
through history
all covered today
every
polished every pair of gloves
sparkling white
everything pressed
as they come to a halt
of
westminster
oh
meanwhile at buckingham palace
royal family prepare
to give up the queen to the nation
from canterbury with the dean of the
chapels royal leading out of the state
entrance
as we see her majesty the queen brought
to the gun carriage
so
and the mall waiting to
embrace
the late queen as she comes through the
canopy of trees here
the late summer
of this extraordinary year of
platinum jubilee
when so much happened down this
processional route
it was just before the queen's
coronation that lord eccles who was
designing
any aspects of it insisted that
iron oxide be mixed with the tarmac
in order to give it a sense of a red
carpet
along which the young queen would travel
[Music]
everybody here witnessing
a royal family in grief
born part of a nation in reflection
right now
the royal family are preparing the queen
for this final journey
[Music]
the royal standard flying at the top of
the mast
to signify that the king is in residence
state color of the
gulf stream guards immediately in front
of the gate
waiting to be lowered
as elizabeth ii leads
through the reflection of those windows
a glimpse of queen's children
thoughts of the nation with the king
and his
siblings
and his two sons who amongst other
members of the royal family will follow
this court age they watch as
queen's company
first battalion grenadier guards bear a
party placed the queen upon the gun
carriage
so
in just one minute
the procession that will take
queen elizabeth ii
on her last journey for her final
act of duty
to lie in state for the nation will
begin
[Music]
senior drum major
mass band of the household division
[Music]
in front of the gun carriage are members
of the lake queens household
led by the major general commanding the
household division
with
the chime of the bell ringing every
minute
immediately in front of the horses
we see the two
pages who looked after the queen
all white roof who appeared
in the famous
representation of the olympics
and
[Music]
for them many members
as the queen
with the imperial state crime passes by
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
the imperial state crime was first worn
by the queen at her coronation in 1953.
it contains stones that tell the whole
story of her kingdom
and today
adorns
an anointed sovereign
being taken to lie in state
[Music]
the king dressed as the marshal of the
royal air force
his sister
princess royal the duke of york
and the earl and wessex and forefather
[Music]
followed by the prince of wales duke of
sussex
peter phillips
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
the escort on either side of the gun
carriage formed by
first battalion grenadier guards you'll
notice that their arms are reversed
swords are turned backwards
the rifles turn back
with the left arm to hold the muzzle
down
all
as an act of respect for the late queen
[Music]
[Music]
the garrison sergeant major mr stokes
who has been preparing these soldiers
leads the king
and his siblings and other members of
the royal family
and in the rear rank of
that family the
earl of snowden and the duke of
gloucester
[Music]
the scarlet tunics of the dismounted
lifeguards from the household cavalry
regiment
leading this parade as the senior
regiment of the british army
[Music]
and watch from the end where buckingham
palace stands by the great statue of
queen victoria
one late sovereign watches
our latest departed queen
make her way towards
westminster the heart
of the nation's constitution
[Music]
one might surmise that the late queen
would
most have her interest
in the horses taking part
after a lifetime loving
anything equestrian
she made the point that
the king's troop who convey her now with
their horses
and their gun carriage
would keep the name her father had given
of king's troop royal horse artillery
they held that title all through her
reign
and now we have a new king
[Music]
at the center of the imperial state
crown
there are four pearl earrings that hang
from the arches where they cross
these are supposed to have come
from scotland and to have been worn once
by
mary queen of scots
[Music]
and the blue sapphire in the cross at
the top
supposedly taken from the
ring finger
of king edward the confessor when his
coffin was translated
from one part of westminster abbey to
the other by king henry iii in the 1200s
i'm watching with eminent pride as their
daughter passes by queen elizabeth we
mother as we remember her
and king george the sixth
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
the procession will shortly turn towards
the right
and pass
[Music]
into horse guards by where horse guards
approach road
[Music]
for the king taking on
the sovereign responsibility
at the death of his mother
must add a great burden to these first
days of kingship
[Music]
the united kingdom flags that adorn the
entire length of the mall give way
in horse guards to the flags of
commonwealth countries including
the other realms of which the queen was
sovereign head
and sovereign
and of the commonwealth itself which was
the heart of so much
that she dedicated her reign to support
[Music]
it was on this corner
in 1981
that the queen was riding to her
birthday parade trooping the color
and someone with a starting pistol fired
shots towards her
no one necessarily knew it was just a
starting pistol and it
it's a reminder of
the courage that must sometimes be
required in public life
to always be at the center
of public events
but the queen very quickly recovered her
horse and with immense composure
took the entire parade
as colonel in chief
of the regiment trooping its color
[Music]
the queen consort
[Music]
princess of wales
[Music]
the countess of wessex and fawfa
and the duchess of sussex leave the
palace and we'll
pass up
bird cage walk and into parliament
square
and a light in palace yard outside
westminster hall awaiting the arrival
of the cortege bringing
the lake queen
[Music]
queenless elizabeth ii was born on the
21st of april 1926.
[Music]
and april being a bad month for weather
normally in the united kingdom
she also used to have an official
birthday
in
the early weeks of june
and always that was marked
with the queen's birthday parade here
in horse guards
and as she passes through our memories
can go back to the countless times on
horseback at the side of her father the
king or as sovereign or in carriage in
later years
she took that salute from her household
division
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
passing under horse guards arch marks
the departure from the
royal grounds and
this was always the main entrance of the
palaces
and those palaces
bit the queen well on this her last
public engagement
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
the blue sashes that members of where
the most noble order of the garter
in this case given to each of them
by the queen
as the order's sovereign head
[Music]
procession turning left into whitehall
and towards parliament square
they will shortly pass the entrance to
10 dining street
and for the queen's constitutional life
she appointed
14 prime ministers inheriting one
in
sir winston churchill her 15th when
she arrived
as sovereign
[Music]
so
[Music]
the queen unveiled this
women at war memorial
with the clothes hanging on it that were
worn by women
helping in the war effort or fighting
themselves
from 1939 to 1945 of course
in 1945
the queen herself as princess elizabeth
joined the army in the
auxiliary territorial force
and in that service she
provided her small part
towards the defeat of the tyranny in
nazi germany
[Music]
so
[Music]
and at the rear of this procession
the blues and royals
who also form part of the household
cavalry dismounted
bringing
the rear of this procession
[Music]
last november the queen was unable to
take part in the annual act of
remembrance at the cenotaph
but she had been to almost every annual
remembrance
and she had stood in front of the
cemetery
beside her father too
her own wartime memories
merged with those of new generations
as so many of her armed forces served
on operations during her reign
[Music]
at its top the cenotaph has the empty
tomb for the thoughts and memories of
all those
families who were affected by war
[Music]
the dad of wars
acknowledging
in silence
the sovereign
whose father and grandfather led them in
the first and second world war
and so many of those who died
during the queen's reign in the army
navy and air force
[Music]
around the gun carriage the
military aquarius who served the queen
from the royal navy the army and the air
force
taking their place as pallbearers for
the sovereign they served
whilst
first battalion grenadier guards march
on either side of them
guarding
elizabeth iii
[Music]
so
[Music]
band of the scots guards
who have
[Music]
carried out this task today
with their director of music
[Music]
and the major general commanding the
household division major general chris
geeker
whose troops including these the king's
troop royal horse artillery
are playing their part in saluting
this former sovereign
[Music]
the queen's personal staff marching in a
row there the
palace steward two of her pages
[Music]
they would have been in close attendance
on the queen
day by day throughout her life
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
the queen passes the statue of sir
winston churchill
as she enters now
parliament square
with a royal salute from the guards of
honor
the procession will turn into that great
palace yard and we can see
[Music]
the massive hall
of westminster waiting
to greet the late sovereign
and we'll witness
as she is taken from the gun carriage
and carried into the heart of that hall
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
oh